[Applause]
we're gonna get into the headlines but
basically i just want to turn the show
over to someone who is basically
one of my heroes writer actress
um
singer
dancer comedian emmy winner emmy winner
she just won the emmy for her amazing
show and she also uh as another one of
her multi-faceted gigs um is now
considered the greatest red carpet
correspondent of our times check out
this viral moment um from the met gala
and it really did go viral now everybody
does it on tik tok so here's the origin
story
i know it ain't i know what i need
[Music]
you know it's your girl
please welcome the one the only kinky
dog
[Applause]
oh
my god you look so amazing i have just
been following you i mean it's just ross
and i have been so excited amazing as
well to do this with you you have a new
collection of essays called southern
belle insults yeah amazon tell us all
about that yeah so lady mitch jacqueline
is one of the characters that i uh came
up with on my page with max and we
literally just did it as like a little
sketch you know what i mean similar to
what you see you know watching snl okay
we do these different sketches so i
started doing that on my page with lady
miss jacqueline and i always had a dream
of like you know what is her world let's
open up lady mitch jacqueline's world
and why is she always being so shady to
this character janet you always just
hear janet in the back like
you know because i was like i want to be
able to kind of you know get into that
world and then the opportunity came up
with amazon and their short stories and
they said hey would you like to write a
you know five stories you know short you
know series of this character and i'm
like let's do it and that's when we
created the world of lady miss jaclyn
which ultimately tells us about the
character that she always is talking
about in the sketches i'm very excited
about people reading it all right well
let's get right into it we've got the
first headline and you know what it's
drew barrymore look at me yes you guys
you have to see tearing up
drew went out on the town
i'm sorry but we have to talk about this
moment
this dress well i wish i could have
talked to kiki i saw it zanna last night
um and michelle michelle turner yes
i um it was just fun i don't go out very
often um i i rarely leave the house um i
mostly sit on my couch and eat take out
food and do my homework and i'm with my
kids uh so it was really fun to step out
and wear christian siriano and just have
that fantasy moment because it's
majoritively sweatpants and takeout so
but that was a movie star moment look at
the twirl when i woke up on the inside
on instagram i was like the truth is the
body for me too that body is snatched
come on
it was it was a fun fantasy well have
you ever considered dressing down the
first time you meet someone okay i love
this story because my girlfriends get on
my case so much if i go out on the rare
blue moon of a date all they talk to me
about is what are you gonna wear
and it's not coming from that like oh
let's get dressed and jojo they're
worried
that i'm gonna wear what i normally wear
in my daily life the wall street journal
reports that the newest trend in dating
is people are showing up in a first date
in sweatpants and little to no makeup
absolutely i am with you yeah yeah no
for sure some say it's like low-key
feels more authentic quick way to weed
people out who don't love you oh my gosh
state okay why do you love this and can
you talk to my girlfriends who are
literally like the sweats have got to
stop you know because the idea is that
if it unless you're wearing makeup then
it means you didn't try but it's like i
did try brush my teeth i washed my face
i put on some clean deodorant i smell
good i put some perfume on but maybe i
don't want to be dressed up tight and
why do i need to pretend to be somebody
else if i'm trying to get you to date me
and i'm telling you i've had great
success when i just kind of been chill
about it and my honestly my mom
encouraged me because i i was talking to
her when i went on a first date like a
couple of months ago and i said you know
what do you think mom like i don't
really feel like doing my makeup i'm
trying to let my skin breathe should i
put my contacts in she said no you like
your glasses wear your glasses you ain't
got to do too much you want to put no
makeup on do it let him see you for who
you are best day i had
best date i had and i felt more at ease
i felt more at ease
all right next we've got a pic from the
little yellow book and that's our list
of stuff that we love it's my personal
curation and i love to share it with
people and it's up on our website we
refresh it every week and today my pick
um is actually from flower um it's our
brand
and it's blue light glasses yes
and blue light glasses as we're all
scrolling and typing and looking at our
screens which we all are um we're gonna
give a pair away to everyone in the
audience
so
i wanted to share these with you
so
i hope you wear them with all the love
that they were made for you with uh kiki
i was wondering if
you
would actually curate and do the entire
little yellow book next week like an all
kiki
next week kiki barber's little yellow
book taking over
[Music]